[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce 13 février
[Musique]
c'est le média le plus consommé au monde
la radio célèbre ce lundi sa journée
mondiale l'occasion pour nous de mettre
en avant les radios locales du
territoire et elles sont nombreuses dans
les Yvelines à relayer l'actualité
informée proposée des émissions diverses
exemples dans cette édition avec Radio
sensation et radio Vexin Val de Seine
le bilan des victimes s'élèvent
désormais à plus de 30 000 morts après
le séisme qui a frappé la Turquie et la
Syrie la semaine dernière la solidarité
s'organise pour venir en aide aux
populations et secours sur place parmi
les actions une collecte était organisée
samedi au marché de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à l'initiative du
Secours populaire français
et puis c'est un duel tant attendu à
Versailles j - 3 avant Ginette le match
de basket qui oppose les lycées
Sainte-Geneviève et Hoche et programmé
jeudi au gymnase Montbauron l'ambiance
s'annonce électrique pour en parler
François Allaman organisateur et les
capitaines des deux équipes seront nos
invités et ce sera tout à l'heure dans
la partie sport avec le retour de
Michael el mis Doro bonsoir le come-back
le come-back après deux semaines
d'absence le come-back tant attendu pour
nous présenter les résultats sportifs du
week-end de quoi va-t-on parler
aujourd'hui
on parlera des Templiers d'Élancourt qui
ont malheureusement perdu dans le
championnat de deuxième division on
parlera également de Versailles qui a
par contre gagné qui est leader de
national donc à beau programme en
perspective au niveau du les viennois et
on va présenter une pépite pépite du
rugby c'est Enzo et ben méga et derrière
Enzo ben méga il y a bien sûr une
famille une famille de rugbymen et
d'ailleurs le père d'Enzo et le frère
d'Enzo Bayonne Mégal frère aîné sont
avec nous en plateau Alec et Mathis
bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir merci d'être
avec toi on va parler de cette passion
pour le rugby qui vous anime Enzo
benmegal pour le présenter il a été
formé au Sky rugby c'était un jeune
ailier du Racing 92 on le voit cette
saison en Top 14 il a connu récemment
ses premières caps en équipe de France
des moins de 20 ans il a d'ailleurs
inscrit le dernier essai lors de la
défaite ce weekend des Bleus en Irlande
33 31 l'exploit était tout proche très
rapidement comment vous avez trouvé sa
prestation Mathis ben plutôt
satisfaisante malgré tout une grande
fierté de le voir marquer son premier
essai sous le maillot des Bleus et puis
un match plutôt satisfaisant de sa part
donc on est très fier de ce qu'il a de
ce qu'il a produit vendredi soir avec et
un match vraiment de très haut niveau
avec beaucoup beaucoup alors comme comme
pour ses frères la fierté de le voir
évoluer sous le maillot de l'équipe de
France un peu de un peu de fierté de
papa j'espère pas mal placé mais en tout
cas très très heureux de le voir
s'épanouir dans son activité
[Musique]
déjà
il va falloir beaucoup beaucoup de place
sur sur l'étagère on fait en sorte parce
que je pense qu'il a pas le temps il est
encore aussi à vivre en direct ces
prestations donc à la maison on s'occupe
de compiler tout ça pour que d'ici
quelques temps il puisse avoir les
souvenirs l'occasion de le présenter un
peu plus tout à l'heure de parler de
cette passion pour le rugby on a on a pu
le suivre sur un entraînement de
l'équipe de France U20 à Marcoussis la
semaine dernière dans un instant
également les informations du jour à
suivre dans le 7 8 mais avant on va
jeter un petit coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
ce mardi matin ça reste froid dans le
département avec le soleil qui sera tout
de même de la partie il fera 0° le matin
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan 1 degré à
Versailles Rambouillet dont l'après-midi
le thermomètre va grimper un petit peu
compter 12 degrés dans la partie sud et
ouest des Yvelines 11 degrés à
Versailles 10 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
et ce mardi 14 février c'est bien
entendu la Saint-Valentin le point à
présent sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines avec les informations à retenir
c'est avec Mathilde Franco
habitants du nord des Yvelines attention
plusieurs rôtis de la marque valgrin
sont rappelés en raison de la présence
de salmonelle il s'agit du rôti savoyard
livré à Carrières-sur-Seine au Relais
Des italiers du rôti de pruneaux livrés
aux Mureaux à l'entrepôt du rôti façon
Orloff livré au Carrefour de Chambourcy
au BDM d'Orgeval et aux Mureaux et des
rôties provençal et chèvres miel livrés
au BDM d'Orgeval le parti politique
d'Eric Zemmour reconquête organisait
samedi dernier une manifestation devant
le domaine de Grignon les partisans
dénoncent la mise en place d'un centre
d'hébergement d'urgence pour 200
migrants indignés une trentaine
d'habitants de la ville de tivernal
Grignon se sont rendus sur place pour
une contre manifestation il n'y a pas eu
de débordement on poursuit avec le
chiffre du jour 25000 il s'agit du
nombre de signalements de coupures
internet dans les Yvelines sur l'année
2022 le département serait le cinquième
territoire de France avec le plus grand
nombre de pannes les chiffres de zone
ADSL le spécialiste du très haut débit
les causes travaux dégradation
intempéries mauvais entretien ou encore
mauvais branchement guettez votre boîte
mail et vos indésirables si vous vous
êtes inscrit pour le tirage au sort de
la billetterie des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 vous allez peut-être être
parmi les chanceux jusqu'au 15 mars vous
pourrez recevoir une notification pour
acheter des billets en pack pour trois
disciplines olympiques prix mini 24
euros prix maxi 690 euros soyez aux
aguets vous n'aurez que 48 heures pour
effectuer la demande et enfin les fans
de jeux vidéo avaient rendez-vous samedi
au Palais des Sports Pierre de Coubertin
de plaisir la ville organisait la
deuxième édition du plaisir gaming au
programme plusieurs tournois sur PC et
console fortnite FIFA ou encore super
smash bros j'étais déjà venu l'année
dernière et c'est il y a clairement une
grande amélioration là il y a beaucoup
plus de monde il y a beaucoup plus de
joueurs
façon tout retrouver les consoles où ma
mère et mon père ou ma maman et mon papa
jouait et puis on est à Just Dance pour
ceux qui aiment bien danser
un ancien gamer entre guillemets j'ai
beaucoup joué étrangère et puis bah je
viens ici pour redécouvrir un peu les
anciennes consoles les nouveaux jeux
cette seconde édition a attiré plus de
1000 personnes la ville de Plaisir
penche déjà sur une troisième édition
[Musique]
et si vous aussi près de chez vous vous
êtes témoin d'un fait d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le
dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
depuis 2011 la radio est célébrée par
une journée mondiale chaque 13 février
c'est une date proclamée par les États
membres de l'UNESCO pour cet outil
impuissant pour je cite célébrer
l'humanité dans toute sa diversité qui
constitue une plateforme pour le
discours démocratique c'est ce que dit
l'UNESCO et c'est l'occasion pour nous
de rappeler que dans les Yvelines et
bien nous sommes gâtés en termes de
radiocale puisque près d'une dizaine
émettent encore aujourd'hui elles sont
associatifs certaines sont nées dans les
années à 80 même juste avant dans le
mouvement des raviolis et pour parler
justement de ces radios locales
yblinoises on a en plateau avec nous
deux invités Corentin Alonso bonsoir
bonsoir journaliste pour Radio sensation
qui émet dans les Yvelines vous êtes
basé à Élancourt sur la fréquence 98.4
mais également dans d'autres zones
puisque la radio est implantée en
Essonne en Normandie et émet aussi sur
le DAB+ à Paris et Rouen et en face de
vous il y a Jean-François denage bonsoir
vous êtes vous le président d'her Obs
pour Radio Vexin Val de Seine qui émet
également dans les Yvelines sur la
fréquence 96.2 vous êtes basé aux
Mureaux je vais faire un premier tour de
table messieurs si je vous dis radio ça
vous évoque quoi qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous la radio Corentin
en voiture c'est ce qui accompagne un
petit peu c'est le moment parfois quand
on part en vacances notamment et puis
même les trajets du quotidien c'est
surtout ça puis parfois j'écoute aussi
la radio le soir avant de m'endormir ça
te permet de déconnecter un peu des des
écrans mais de rester un petit peu
d'apprendre toujours des choses et un
côté mystère quand j'étais jeune autour
de la radio de pas savoir forcément le
connaître le visage du présentateur il y
avait toute une part de mystère savoir
que ça représente quoi pour vous la
Radio la radio pour moi ça représente
l'information à la communication surtout
et puis des choses que nous ne
connaissions pas à l'époque on a
découvert avec la radio les différentes
musiques les différents sons d'outre-mer
et d'ailleurs c'est vraiment vraiment
à écouter et puis c'est vrai en vacances
en vacances et bien ces différentes
radios que nous écoutions et pas tant
que maintenant mais dans la voiture et
bien on chantait on était accompagné
donc de radio d'actualité et puis
d'information oui c'est finalement le
média on sait se porter on s'intéresse à
la voix avant tout et on l'associe comme
le disait Corentin comme vous le disiez
à des souvenirs des souvenirs d'enfance
parfois des souvenirs et de vie pourquoi
à votre avis ça reste un média à part et
qu'il faut défendre face à d'autres
médias peut-être qui est aussi
complémentaire avec le média de la
télévision par exemple mais pourquoi
c'est un média à part selon vous la
médié à part parce que c'est un moyen de
communication on va dire assez facile
pour la proximité surtout voilà le comme
sur RVVS sur Radio avec 12 scène le
droit de parole est donné un peu à tout
le monde à toutes les personnes qui le
souhaitent nous allons donc sur
différents forums sur différents faits
d'associations pour justement aller à la
proximité de des personnes de l'auditeur
qui a un message à passer
[Musique]
que radio avec ça Val-de-Seine c'était à
la base donc c'est la base de la radio
c'est la puériculture le pluralisme
toutes les communautés sont représentées
il y a différentes émissions qui sont
représentées dans cette radio et
justement ce droit de parole qu'on ne
retrouve pas ailleurs j'insiste
là-dessus puisque les radios
communautaires on en a pas tant que ça
et sur une seule radio on a plusieurs
communautés et ça c'est une richesse
c'est une richesse d'expression droite
parole et Corentin disait aussi plus de
facilité pour les personnes interviewées
de de s'exprimer et aussi différents
sujets à aborder on va en parler dans un
instant mais on peut parler de tout
aussi à la radio exactement nous à Radio
sensation on parle vraiment de tous les
sujets que ce soit de la culture soit le
tissu associatif qui est hyper riche
dans la plupart des villes on essaye de
le mettre en avant alors les
associations c'est qu'elles soient
sportives économiques les politiques
aussi on essaye de faire vivre le débat
le débat politique au niveau local ce
qui est important d'avoir des médias
locaux pour faire vivre la démocratie et
puis
par exemple à la culture italienne
également des émissions aussi sur sur
les DOM-TOM il me semble tout à fait il
y a des sièges au soleil DOM-TOM il y a
la culture italienne il y a les cerbes
aussi qui ont une émission il y a le CD
Sénégal enfin le Sénégalais qui ont une
émission justement le peuple qui qui
communique aussi en direct via le
Sénégal par par Internet bien sûr mais
voilà c'est tout cette communication
alors je n'irai pas jusqu'à l'Europe
puisque nous sommes restés vraiment
local comme vous savez nous sommes nous
sommes des bénévoles une quarantaine de
bénévoles à bénévès une seule salarié
qui est la secrétaire d'ailleurs que je
salue qui fait des montages qui fait qui
fait un peu tout qui est secrétaire qui
est employé mais qui fait aussi beaucoup
de choses pour pour l'association et et
il est vrai que pour la la communication
nous avons un journaliste pour tout ce
qui est actualité tout ce qui est actu
homme politique de proximité etc que ce
soit pour les municipales ou les
présidentielles par exemple on a
Monsieur Robert Congo qui qui gère qui
gère toute cette partie en tout cas
c'est
la radio de proximité
est très importante on le ressent avec
les auditeurs les les personnes qu'on
nous annonce sur différentes
manifestations et bien ils viennent
toujours vers la radio parce que c'est
un moyen de communication pour eux et
ils yiennent et c'est vrai que pour
aborder les les grandes radios c'est ce
qui me disent toujours on va passer sur
d'autres radios ce n'est pas évident
tandis que là on va vers eux ils
viennent vers nous donc il y a un
échange qui apporte beaucoup de choses
et beaucoup de richesses culturelles sur
les zones RVS un Corte à côté formateur
aussi il y a Laurent Romejko qui a
débuté sur RVS et d'autres qui ont
débuté sur RVVS Laurent qui est passé il
y a pas très longtemps revoir un peu les
studios etc c'est un temps plein on
reçoit beaucoup de beaucoup de jeunes
d'écoles de journalistes qui sont là des
jeunes de stagiaires de 3e aussi qui
viennent on en avoir sur moi qui qui
vient une semaine en découverte et puis
d'autres qui reviennent par la suite
parce que ça accroché et donc c'est un
tremplin pour les futurs journalistes en
face de vous d'ailleurs Corentin qui
débute sa carte de journaliste qui
débute à sensation j'en suis aussi
quelque chose puisque j'ai commencé à
Radio sensation il y a forcément un côté
formateur je voulais terminer avec une
dernière question très générale est-ce
que la Radio la radio associative locale
a un bel avenir devant elle selon vous
Corentin bah oui tant que tant que les
les élus locaux aussi
s'impliquent dans dans ces médias tant
qu'ils s'investissent c'est ce genre de
radio ne peut que avoir de l'avenir
puisque il parle des citoyens de
l'actualité locale et c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui un outil de démocratie
important après c'est dans la main des
élus locaux qui financent avec les
subventions et puis le ministère de la
Culture aussi avec les subventions
notamment du du FSEA oui les élus locaux
très important les subventions les
subventions alors chez nous il y a pas
de publicité donc voilà ce sont les
subventions qui qui nous font vivre en
ce moment les c'est quand même difficile
avec tous les augmentations
d'électricité etc je le dis parce que
oui on a encore de l'avenir on est
encore là on va se battre pour voilà
mais il faut pas lâcher surtout pas
parce que c'est un outil de proximité
très important pour la population merci
Jean-François Denain merci Corentin
lonzo d'être venu célébrer en plateau
cette journée mondial de la radio bonne
fête à vous et merci encore d'être venu
sur ce plateau alors dans l'actualité
également il y a les suites des
puissances séismes qui ont frappé la
Turquie et la Syrie la semaine dernière
qui ont fait plus de 30000 morts un
bilan qui pourrait même doubler selon
l'ONU depuis la catastrophe la
solidarité se met en place nous vous
parlions la semaine dernière de ces
pompiers yvelinois qui ont été envoyés
indirectement sur place pour prêter main
forte au secouriste il y a aussi le
Secours populaire qui organisé de son
côté une collecte pour aider les
populations sur place c'était samedi sur
le marché de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
céline-charles et Julien Leroy ils sont
venus nombreux ce samedi au marché de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux une quinzaine de
bénévoles du Secours populaire des
Yvelines et du mouvement d'enfants
copains du monde se sont réunis pour une
collecte de fonds bonjour monsieur
collègue de fonds pour l'urgence séisme
en Turquie et en Syrie
merci beaucoup après le séisme qui a
frappé le sud de la Turquie et la Syrie
l'association veut contribuer à l'effort
collectif 100.000 euros de fonds
d'urgence ont déjà été débloqués par le
Secours populaire français mon sexe ça
va durer des mois voir des années la
situation et donc du coup on fait valoir
le travail de notre réseau
euromeditarenéen pour nous permettre
d'accompagner les personnes dans la
reconstruction que ce soit de leur vie
de leur habitat et de tous les espaces
publics qui ont été dégradés
le principal est de permettre à chacun
de pouvoir être solidaire
pour la Turquie
merci beaucoup bonne journée ça m'a
beaucoup ému de me dire que enfin c'est
des gens comme nous enfin surtout de
voir que j'avais mon ami qui était dans
ce pays enfin dans un pays à côté et te
dire que bah genre ça aurait pu être
nous et c'est enfin ils ont notre âge
ils sont comme nous et eux ils ont un
homme séisme avec autant de moi mais en
général dès que je peux plutôt sur une
collecte et faire des dons régulièrement
pour pour aider finalement un peu tout
le monde et que ça soit utilisé à bon
escient je pense que tout le monde a
besoin d'un petit coup de pouce à un
moment donné donc c'est toujours bien de
donner de sa poche quand on peut il me
dit que les catastrophes naturelles
c'est quand même très compliqué à
anticiper donc les personnes n'ont pas
eu de chance que ça tombait sur elle
quoi pour pouvoir aider comme ça c'est
c'est bien je trouve au total 1071 euros
ont été récoltés d'autres actions sont
organisées partout dans le département
la ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye par
exemple voté une aide exceptionnelle de
10000 euros en faveur des populations
sinistrées
voilà pour ces actualités on va parler à
présence sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et vous êtes revenu en plateau Michael
ennemi Doro en compagnie de nos invités
on commence par parler rugby dans cette
émission retenez bien son nom Enzo ben
méga a connu ses premières sélections
avec l'équipe de France moins de 20 ans
de rugby lors du tournoi des 6 nations
2023 19 ans liviennois connaît une
saison
2022-2023 de rêve première
titularisation en Top 14 avec le Racing
92 premier pas au niveau international
alors qui est ce jeune joueur qui a
touché ses premiers ballons au Sky rugby
la réponse dans ce portrait réalisé par
Nicolas dandry
[Musique]
à 19 ans Enzo benmegal compte deux
sélections avec l'équipe de France moins
de 20 ans une première apparition sous
le maillot bleu face à l'Italie lors du
tournoi des 6 nations 2023 un souvenir
gravé à jamais dans sa mémoire
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
représente vraiment notre pays c'est
vraiment l'identité de la France et puis
après le match en Italie c'est juste
énorme en plus on avait des supporters
puis faire des matchs sur des stades où
il y a beaucoup de monde c'est ça donne
toujours envie c'est toujours des bons
moments qu'on passe là depuis qu'on est
petit le but c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible de jouer en pro de faire des
sélections un maximum du coup c'est un
peu le début d'un rêve qui se réalise
talentueux s'exprime à travers sa
vitesse et ses appuis des qualités
physiques qu'il met au service du
collectif c'est un incroyable joueur
finisseur rapide
qui désordre c'est-à-dire qu'il va se
proposer un peu partout sur le terrain
et cet esprit d'initiative
nous intéresse donc voilà pourquoi enzo
est parmi nous enzo a commencé le rugby
en mini poussin à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines son premier
club c'est le skyrugby et la suivi ses
deux grands frères Mathis et Alix c'est
mon plus grand frère donc Mathis qui a
commencé en faire puis ça a été suivi
par mon autre frère et bah je suis allé
par automatisme ça s'est bien passé donc
j'ai continué et dans la catégorie moins
de 14 ans il rejoint le Racing 92 le
plus jeune de la fratrie fera ses gammes
dans le club des Hauts-de-Seine des
Minimes jusqu'aux espoirs pour jouer ces
deux premiers matchs de Top 14 en
septembre 2022 franchement le début de
saison c'était une grande surprise et
vraiment que du plaisir je me attendais
pas du tout et de faire les deux
premiers matchs de Top 14 des titulaires
et de voir tout ce qui est tout ce qui a
eu autour c'était juste magique le but
final c'est la Coupe du monde après pour
le prix faut passer par par le 6 nations
faire des bonnes performances que ça
soit en sélection en club et puis après
on espère que si tout se passe bien la
Coupe du Monde sera sur le chemin le
championnat du monde des moins de 20 ans
aura lieu du 24 juin au 14 juillet en
Afrique du Sud et du 15 au 30 juillet au
Kenya
portrait de Nicolas dandry mais avec la
voix de Mathilde Franco et on disait
tout à l'heure Michael on est avec nous
en plateau pour parler d'Enzo benmegal
de Alec ben Megane et de Mathis qui est
donc sont les le père et le frère de de
d'Enzo quel regard déjà vous portez sur
cette mise en lumière récente de votre
jeune frère en plus vous l'avez initié
un peu au rugby c'est ce qui est dit
dans le reportage on aura l'occasion
d'en parler mais quel regard vous portez
là sur cette ascension vraiment une
grande fierté parce qu'on se rend pas
compte au final de du chemin qui est
parcouru le voir comme on l'a pu voir
sur les images tout petit sur ses
premiers ses premiers ballons et puis
ben c'est un parcours qui s'est fait
petit à petit et puis on est encore
surpris ben là de de le voir à la
télévision avec les grands sur des
matchs de Top 14 donc vraiment une
énorme fierté et qui qui nous procure à
chaque fois qui m'a qui gravit les
étapes et qui qui gravit les échelons
également c'est la fierté le premier
sentiment qui vous anime oui la fierté
mais aussi c'est j'allais dire c'est
c'est presque un chemin qui qui se fait
petit à petit il a commencé comme tous
les enfants dans le club local avec pas
forcément les ambitions de vouloir
performer ou de réussir il y a pour les
copains pour se dépenser et puis petit à
petit ben on passe d'un club à l'autre
on prend un statut supplémentaire donc
les choses se font se font au fur et à
mesure des années et puis c'est vrai que
c'est quand on se retourne qu'on regarde
les sacrifices qu'il a pu faire parce
que je sais des choses aussi
qu'on a du mal parfois à percevoir c'est
que pour en arriver là
moi ça fait un paquet d'années que je le
vois plus prendre de vacances les étés
c'est les salles de musculation c'est
les séances tout seul parce que tout
c'est pas forcément en club donc voilà
c'est je suis très fier de des efforts
et des commandes des sacrifices qu'il a
pu accomplir pour en arriver là où il en
est aujourd'hui même si ça venait
ça met que le début et puis c'est très
très éphémère
demain tout peut s'arrêter pour des
blessures pour des de la motivation qui
n'est plus au rendez-vous les
performances pour inexplicablement enfin
pour pas expliquer les exigence
effectivement une roue qui peut tourner
très vite dans le sport de haut niveau
nickel oui et il a joué ce weekend
contre l'Irlande lors du tournoi des 6
nations chez les moins de 20 ans les
Français ont perdu 33 à 31 enzo a marqué
un essai comment vous l'avez trouvé Enzo
alors
c'est vrai que l'essai c'est un petit
peu la cerise sur le gâteau mais le
match a été très très compliqué les les
Français ont été un peu bousculés
notamment dans sur les zones de combat
du coup il a il a pas eu les ballons
qu'il aurait peut-être permis de
s'exprimer comme on disait dans le
reportage à l'instant c'est ses qualités
de vitesse d'appui ont été un peu
annihilés par le fait que les ballons
étaient très très difficilement
exploitable et donc les bennes Mégal
c'est avant tout une famille de
passionnés de de rugby il y a vous
Matisse il y a également Alix il y a
aussi Enzo du coup du coup comment elle
est venue cette passion du rugby est-ce
que ça vient du père la passion pour le
rugby comment elle a été transmise
comment elle est née dans cette famille
et pas du tout non c'est assez drôle
puisque elle a passé plus une punition
qu'autre chose
on a toujours été une famille plutôt
sportive on est passé par plusieurs
sports et à l'époque je faisais du foot
tu es passionné de foot mais les parents
l'étaient un petit peu moins et ce qui
fait que ils ont voulu m'orienter vers
le rugby je voulais pas du tout et on
avait fait un deal il m'avait dit ben tu
fais un entraînement de rugby et si
jamais ça te plaît
on fait le rugby ça te plaît pas tu
retournes au foot là vous avez quel âge
25 à ce moment-là je devais avoir 10 ans
entre 10 et 12 ans et le premier le
premier entraînement j'ai pas du tout
accroché et puis j'ai dit ben tant pis
je retourne au foot et finalement mes
parents ont sorti à bellecarte dû nous a
compris l'essai c'est un essai d'un an
c'est on t'a pris la licence donc c'est
parti et puis finalement je suis j'évite
été pris au jeu je me suis tombé je suis
tombé dedans la passion a pris et puis
derrière les deux frères en suivi
également à 50 ans Yvelines les débuts
du coup alors que nous on le souhaitait
pas parce qu'on voulait qu'ils aient
chacun un peu leur domaine leur petit
jardin à eux qui soient pas dans la
comparaison donc on voulait que les
petits frères fassent autre chose et ben
le destin on a décidé autrement et et
voilà quoi
aujourd'hui sont des rugbymen exactement
donc avec Mathis qui qui joue à Plaisir
voilà Alix qui est qui qui gagne sa vie
en jouant au rugby aussi donc là il
était jusqu'à présent sur le club de
Beaune en National et puis il prépare la
saison à 7 puisque lui il est vraiment
profilé
seven comme on dit un sentiment que vous
anime justement c'est de la fierté alors
c'est de la fierté c'est beaucoup je
vous cache pas parce que
j'adore les voir réussir forcément comme
tous parents mais en même temps je suis
conscient de
difficulté des des enjeux que ça peut
avoir sur la santé sur leur santé
psychologique aussi parce que c'est pas
toujours facile que d'accepter de rater
un match de pas être au niveau attendu
donc voilà en tant que papa des fois ça
m'est arrivé de dire à des copains ah il
sort ouf mais comment ça ils sortent tu
es content oui c'est pas fait mal et
voilà mais même s'ils ont grandi vous
êtes toujours très présent oui oui oui
on est enfin de toute façon on est un
peu obligé à la maison
ça parle quasiment que de ça si c'est
pas l'un c'est l'autre la maman est
impliquée aux racines elle a été
dirigeante jusqu'à cette année voilà
donc du coup non non c'est quelque chose
qui est qui a imprégné fortement la vie
de famille du coup les frères ont voulu
suivre votre exemple vous les avez
initié vous leur avez montré la voix en
quelque sorte on a toujours été très
proche les des autres on avançait
souvent suivi sur les jeux sur le sport
etc donc ben ça s'est fait très
naturellement sur ma propre après ma
première année de rugby Alix a suivi
ensuite et Enzo ça a été un petit peu
plus compliqué il avait des tendances à
être un petit peu un petit peu plus
sauvage petit et ben pour l'amener à
faire du sport et puis il y a un petit
peu plus s'intégrer ben il est venu au
rugby et puis la mayonnaise à tout de
suite pris et ben derrière le parcours
s'en est suivi au fur et à mesure vous
jouez ensemble des fois on joue ensemble
l'été l'été on s'amuse toujours ensemble
un petit peu sur les moments
d'entraînement on n'a pas trop eu
l'occasion de de jouer ensemble dans les
mêmes équipes déjà avec Enzo par rapport
à l'écart d'âge et puis l'écart de
niveau c'est quand même fait assez
rapidement mais on se retrouve très
régulièrement pour pour jouer avec un
petit peu de ballon les séances un petit
peu personnelles les faire ensemble sur
les temps sur les temps de pause et les
temps de préparation donc non on se très
souvent autour du ballon le confinement
a été on a un petit bout on a la chance
d'avoir un petit bout de jardin a été
exactement où on a pu retrouver les
trois à jouer ensemble et beaucoup
beaucoup pendant cette période là et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure c'est le
monde du haut niveau et forcément
exigeant un monde difficile ou tout peut
aller très vite comment vous êtes auprès
de justement d'Enzo comment vous vous
l'accompagnez vous l'entourez dans ce
moment aussi de mise en lumière où il
faut savoir gérer aussi plein plein de
nouveaux aspects alors il a il a eu la
chance Enzo d'avoir son frère Alix qui
est passé par des structures comme Massy
le Racing avec évidemment les les joies
les les moments de bonheur mais aussi
les désillusions quand on n'est pas
gardé dans dans une équipe parce que Ben
un moment le niveau fait que Ben vous
demande d'aller voir ailleurs si
si on n'y serait pas mieux donc du coup
c'est des choses c'est des discours
qu'on a tenu très très vite sur tu es
content d'être là mais si tu es là c'est
parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est plus à
ta place donc un jour peut-être que toi
aussi tu seras bien obligé de laisser la
place à quelqu'un d'autre on les a aussi
beaucoup accompagnés sur le plan
logistique c'est-à-dire que juste une
aujourd'hui il est pris en charge
quasiment à 100% par le Racing sur
l'hébergement des choses comme ça mais
ces structures là en région parisienne
elles sont elles sont peut-être moins
prégnantes que en province et on en a
fait des kilomètres avec Alix avec
Matisse avec Enzo
tous les vendredis soirs à Colombes
trois fois par semaine
merci papi pour les allers-retours aussi
en semaine pour amener les enfants à
l'école voilà d'autant que les garçons
sont passés aussi par le la section
sportive de plaisir de Guillaume
Apollinaire donc voilà
on y a fait quelques kilomètres voilà
donc entre l'intendance et puis le
discours un petit peu pour tempérer les
ardeurs voilà on a essayé assez connu
une dernière question la question que je
me pose c'est comment vous faites pour
voir tous les matchs de de vos fils et
comment vous organisez tout simplement
le weekend alors
on a eu la chance souvent d'avoir des
matchs le samedi et le dimanche
on a fait aussi pas mal de déplacements
avec avec la voiture ou avec le les
transports organisés par les clubs et
puis on a la chance aujourd'hui d'avoir
énormément de matchs qui sont diffusés
par les par Internet enfin ce type de
réseaux sociaux ou et la télévision
aussi de temps en temps donc voilà on ne
suit pas on ne suit pas tous les matchs
en physique on va suivre la suite des
aventures avec attention merci Alex
merci Mathis d'être venu en plateau pour
pour parler de cette carrière d'Enzo
début de car on l'espère une carrière
très longue et oreiller de plein de
succès on va maintenant passer Michael
aux autres résultats sportifs du
week-end on va commencer par du football
dans le championnat de National
Versailles s'est imposé ce vendredi soir
sur sa pelouse face à Orléans le score 3
buts avec notamment un doubler de
l'attaquant néerlandais
au classement Versailles reprend la
première place avec 36 points engrangé
depuis le début de la saison juste en
dessous le championnat national 2 l'as
Poissy continent engranger des points
les petits saké se sont imposés deux un
sur le terrain de Rouen à l'occasion de
la 18e journée du championnat check
Touré encore marqué il a marqué deux
buts cette fois-ci laisse-toi site
actuellement à la troisième place du
championnat on va parler également d'une
course à pied ce week-end c'est le cross
de la sablière le cross de la sablière
tout à fait on va le voir sur ces images
le 41e cross de la sablière était
organisée ce dimanche 12 février cette
année plus de 1000 coureurs se sont
donnés rendez-vous au parc forestier de
Viroflay avec au programme des courses
pour les enfants ainsi que le mettre à
11 km l'événement a également permis de
récolter des bouchons pour des
négociation le rendez-vous reviendra
pour une 42e édition l'année prochaine
une autre course à 50 ans en Yvelines ce
dimanche 12 février c'était la dixième
édition de la Bike & Run de la minière à
Guyancourt au programme une course de 15
km ou deux participants se passent un
vélo sur la distance de la course cette
course faisait partie du challenge Ile
de France ce rendez-vous organisés par
le triathlon club de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a réuni
plusieurs dizaines de participants
Patrick Jacques de dixmu était sur place
juste avant le départ donc ça circuit de
15 km donc sur trois boucles
avec deux trois difficultés avec donc
deux montées au milieu du parcours et
puis une montée à la fin donc mais c'est
vraiment que des parcours en forêt
autour des étangs de temps de la bière
les résultats sont à retrouver sur le
site internet du triathlon club de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui s'affiche
il y avait également du cyclisme sur
piste ce week-end les championnats
d'Europe de cyclisme sur piste ce sont
clôturés ce week-end en Suisse 11
médailles récoltées par l'équipe de
France l'équipe de France qui a plutôt
bien réussi ce rendez-vous mais la
France a apporté qu'une seule médaille
d'or avec Benjamin Thomas sur l'Omnium
parmi les satisfactions il y a eu une
très belle médaille d'argent de Marie
divine quoi mais sur le 500 m elle qui
s'entraîne comme tous les pistes
tricolores du côté du Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines tout ce Beaumont
se retrouve à l'année prochaine lors des
Jeux olympiques de Paris en 2024 dans
les Yvelines au Vélodrome bien sûr déjà
hâte ce dimanche également une
compétition de trampoline c'est une
discipline dont on parle pas souvent les
disciplines insolites mais ça avait lieu
ce weekend à Guyancourt ce dimanche à
Bayeux une compétition du coup de
trampoline le rendez-vous était organisé
au gymnase de l'aviation à Guyancourt a
réuni plus de 140 sportifs l'événement
compté pour les compétitions fédérales
de trampoline on écoute un organisateur
micro de TV 78 il nous présente le
système de notation dans cette
discipline le mode de jugement s'appuie
finalement sur quatre critères donc vous
allez avoir 6 juges qui évalue la
qualité de l'exécution donc de la
comment réaliser les figures les jambes
sont-elles tendues les bras sentiers de
la alignés après on a deux juges qui
évaluent la difficulté de l'exercice
donc il y a un code qui
évalue donne une valeur à chaque figure
et donc le but entre pauline est d'en
réaliser 10 d'affilée on est en direct
des invités de rejoignent en plateau
mais Michael où il est terminé avec un
mot de football américain alors il y a
pas que le super ball je sais pas si
d'ailleurs on va poser la question à nos
invités on va les présenter dans un
instant vous avez suivi le Super Bowl de
loin de loin j'ai regardé ce matin un
résumé du match moi pas du tout c'est
que le basket juste en face vous voulez
regarder bien moi j'ai regardé en entier
37 35 pour les petits matchs
avec la victoire des chips qui sont
adjugés je crois leur troisième Super
Bowl moi aussi j'ai fait nuit blanche
aussi pour la prestation de Rihanna la
mi-temps Mickaël moi j'ai dormi je
voulais avoue mais par contre j'ai
regardé forcément ce matin le bah le
concert de Rihanna et des 13 minutes de
concerts et j'ai pu voir aussi le
résultat est très belle performance
ce week-end il y avait le championne 2e
division casque d'or avec nos Templiers
les Templiers d'Élancourt et oui à
Grégory un mauvais résultat pour les
Templiers d'Élancourt les élans courtois
se sont inclinés 34 à 6 sur le terrain
des Diables Rouges de Villepinte à
l'occasion de la troisième journée du
championnat de 2e division c'est la
troisième défaite de la saison pour les
Templiers en trois matchs disputés
l'objectif de la montée semble de plus
en plus compliqué ils sont dernier de la
poule pour l'instant et on parle à
présent de basket avec nos invités je
les ai pas présenté bonsoir à vous qui
nous ont rejoint pour un et derby
sulfureux on va parler de ce derby qu'on
a pu suivre l'année dernière on l'a
suivi aussi dans les dans les autres
éditions c'est ce jeudi à 20h de lycée
Versailles qui vont s'affronter d'un
côté Sainte-Geneviève et de l'autre côté
le lycée Hoche pour nous en parler donc
il y a plusieurs invités François
Allaman qui est l'organisateur de cet
événement les deux capitaines également
des deux équipes Maxime Gérard et
Antoine guidon qui est qui parce qu'on
appelle le temps de faire connaissance
moi c'est Maxime Maxime donc Maxime
guidon pour Maxime Gérard pour Ginette
et Antoine guidon pour Hoche c'est bien
ça alors l'événement va fêter sa 17e
édition cette année pour les
téléspectateurs qui connaissent pas
justement Ginette contre Hoche quel est
le principe de ce match François lamant
alors ce sont deux prépas qui
s'affrontent depuis 17 ans de prépa qui
s'offre un derby une fois par an je vais
donner une une petite analogie mais sans
prétention un petit Oxford Cambridge
sauce versaillaise avec un peu de mars
madness
saupoudrer ça a fait un cocktail
explosif
très américaine on a l'impression de
retrouver l'ambiance des campus
américains un petit peu exactement
universitaire et avec beaucoup
d'animations en plus des spectacles des
spectacles des spectacles et puis un
match que tout le monde attend les deux
écoles attendent ça on voit beaucoup de
gens sur les images archives de l'année
dernière mille étudiants qui étaient
réunis il y en aura plus de 1000 même
réunis au gymnase Montbauron c'est
attendu avec impatience
ouais l'ambiance est là on peut le dire
surchauffer on peut le dire à quelques
jours là on a j - 30 ce derby oui les
deux écoles se préparent depuis des mois
les ultras le public ils seront déguisés
tête bleue tête rouge des champs appris
des écharpes des t-shirts ça va être fou
vous confirmez Maxime Antoine c'est
chaud là moi j'ai moins 3 l'ambiance se
monte bah forcément il y a des gens qui
préparent ça depuis longtemps des élèves
mais aussi forcément les du basket donc
ouais l'ambiance monte les gens ont hâte
et enfin au basket aussi on a hâte de
jouer ce match donc moi ça fait quelque
chose je pense que c'est la même chose
pour gagner pour faire comme l'année
dernière donc beaucoup de d'attentes
alors si je me trompe pas vous étiez sur
le parquet l'année dernière tous les
deux ça fait quoi de jouer devant autant
de monde
j'ai joué un peu en régional et en
départemental c'est vrai que 1300
personnes c'est la chance je pense qu'il
y a des pros qui le vivent pas en Pro B
par exemple et du coup vraiment c'est
c'est impressionnant au début on est un
peu un peu choqué mais on s'habitue au
fur et à mesure et d'ailleurs c'est bien
passé de l'autre côté donc c'était plus
facile à dire non mais c'est pas ça
c'est que c'est aussi tous nos amis
forcément c'est tous les gens enfin des
gens qu'on a envie de rendre fier on
joue pour l'école et un peu une rivalité
aussi donc forcément c'est essayer
quelque chose de plus et c'est comme tu
le disais c'est moi je joue aussi un peu
au basket avant club mais il y avait
enfin au maximum votre personnalité
tribu qui parlait par moments alors que
là tout le temps il y a du bruit on
entend rien on est c'est compliqué enfin
tout est plus compliqué donc c'est cette
expérience assez incroyable et comment
on fait pour gérer la pression justement
Maxime je pense que il faut se préparer
avant là je pense qu'on a un avantage
nous en tant que deuxième année c'est
qu'on n'a jamais on l'a déjà joué une
fois donc forcément on arrive on sait à
quoi s'attendre
je pense qu'il faut aussi mettre dans sa
bulle et essayer de parler avec son
équipe essayer de pas rentrer dans
toutes les forêt de l'événement parce
que très vite on s'y perd et on joue
plus au basket on fait partie du show
quoi Antoine nous on l'a un peu pris au
début de l'année au début du match la
pression c'était un peu compliqué mais
heureusement on a eu des coachs on a eu
ce sera notre coach cette année qui nous
a un peu recadré nous a aidé à vivre le
moment donc ça c'est un peu libéré au
fur et à mesure et vous le disiez c'est
très bien passé pour auch l'année
dernière avec une victoire c'est quoi le
bilan dans dans ce derby qui mène au
bilan des confrontations de coach
puisque je suis coach aussi à
organisateur et prof de PS à
Sainte-Geneviève 14 à 2
14 pour Sainte-Geneviève oui à deux donc
deuxième victoire l'année dernière mais
c'était quelque chose d'énorme
et d'ailleurs à sur ce rendez-vous vous
avez des personnalités un prestigieuses
dans les tribunes il y a également
régulièrement Frédéric vaisselle qui est
médaille d'argent aux JO avec la France
on l'écoute tout de suite
c'est la première fois que je vois ce
genre de match c'est vrai que j'ai eu la
chance de jouer dans des équipes où il y
avait du monde qui venait mais c'était
au niveau professionnel là des j'allais
dire universitaires qui jouent les uns
contre les autres et qui amène autant de
monde qui met autant d'ambiance et
encore une fois avec autant d'animations
autour j'ai jamais vu je serai là mais
je suis là depuis trois ans donc je vais
continuer oui bien sûr moi c'est ma
première sur ce derby l'année dernière
je suis assez d'accord à avec Frédéric
on vous le dit à chaque fois les
personnes qui découvrent ce derby que
c'est une ambiance qu'on voit nulle part
ailleurs c'est une très belle surprise
oui je suis même moi-même surpris après
une progression fulgurante en quelques
années
d'attirer des grands noms du basket et
cette année il y en aura encore
je peux pas dire tous les noms mais pour
faire un teasing il y aura de belles
personnalités
il y aura sûrement des surprises il y
aura de très grosses surprises
non j'ai quelques informations mais je
peux pas les divulguer non plus mais oui
je pense qu'il y aura il y aura du beau
monde en tout cas si on peut peut-être
voir peut-être le sujet de préparation
parce que l'équipe ça se peaufinent leur
préparation sur ces derniers dernières
semaines un match sulfureux qui qui se
prépare un reportage que j'ai réalisé
quelques jours
[Musique]
le gros problème que vous avez c'est que
vous faites un flex comme vous récitez
une poésie aujourd'hui au lycée
Sainte-Geneviève les joueurs qui
participeront au match de basket face au
lycée Hoche répète leur fondamentaux les
sportifs s'entraînent collectivement
chaque semaine et parfois le soir
individuellement afin d'être prêt pour
ce match amical programmer le 16 février
bah tu l’année dernière ils veulent
prendre leur revanche face à leur Evo
depuis quelques semaines les gens le
Ginetta je commence à leur trotter dans
la tête et on commence vraiment à se
donner à fond et on sent une vraie c'est
super sur le terrain d'intensité on
monte ensuite au niveau forcément parce
que la pression ça joue c'est un jeu de
mental au final le basket donc forcément
les gens se donnent à fond parce qu'ils
ont envie de tout donner au Ginette
entraînement intensif également du côté
des cheerleaders du lycée
Sainte-Geneviève elles assureront le
spectacle sur le parquet pendant les
pauses
chaque semaine pendant une heure et
demie plus de 30 cheerleaders sont
présentes pour répéter elle travaille
sur la chorégraphie depuis fin octobre
en fait l'idée c'est de faire beaucoup
de
groupes avec plein de références à
Ginette si possible et puis on mixe un
peu donc les chorégraphies avec la danse
et puis donc les porter ce qu'on appelle
stunt donc des filles qui volent dans
les airs etc ici l'équipe est
entièrement gérée par des élèves
objectifs réalisés un show à la hauteur
de l'événement et surtout à la hauteur
des cheerleaders du lycée Hoche bien sûr
tout le monde a envie d'avoir le plus
belle chorégraphie et on a vraiment hâte
de découvrir la Corée que Hoche à
préparer parce qu'à chaque fois c'est
très inspirant justement du côté du
lycée Hoche on prépare également entre
les cours depuis la rentrée comme pour
leur rivaux la préparation est intensive
[Musique]
deux entraînements sont organisés chaque
semaine avec notamment au programme des
portées franchement on est pas mal du
tout
quasiment on présente quatre
chorégraphies et là on est en train de
terminer aujourd'hui la quatrième et
dernière chorégraphie sachant qu'il nous
reste encore quelques entraînements donc
en fait ensuite ce sera juste de la
répétition donc on est vraiment bien là
[Musique]
j - 3 avant ce derby est-ce que vous
êtes prêts dans les dans les deux lycées
nous je pense qu'on est prêt on va tout
donner et on a vraiment hâte d'être
jeudi soir
quelques trucs ajuster encore mais on a
l'aide d'un coach qui vient d'arriver
parce qu'on n'avait pas au début donc je
pense que là ça devrait aller
entraînement ce soir pour exactement ça
Ginette c'est fini donc c'est fini bah
forcément j'ai quand même s'entraîner un
peu de son côté tout seul mais
instruments collectifs ouais c'est fini
tout est tout est prêt j'espère vous le
disiez très bonne équipe cette année il
y a forcément on essaye de réunir les
meilleurs joueurs on a eu des pères par
rapport à l'année dernière parce qu'on
avait beaucoup de personnes qui ont
intégrées donc des pertes mais oui on a
réussi à trouver des bons joueurs donc
je pense que la continuité peut
s'établir le niveau à Sainte-Geneviève
je pense que c'est bon aussi après c'est
une soirée c'est bien parce que les gens
qui sont très forts et qui dans la
soirée très mal ce soir là faut une
mauvaise performance donc on verra bien
mais on a des bons éléments et je pense
qu'on peut faire que ça devient par le
sous le contrôle du coach je suis
d'accord donc comment et comment on fait
pour faire grandir un événement comme
comme celui-là
oui parce que c'est avant tout une très
belle aventure qui commence en septembre
qui finit en février chaque année qui a
cette spécificité de m'attirer que les
élèves dans le temps présent et on bat
les cartes et on recommence chaque année
voilà
comment on fait beaucoup de passions
beaucoup d'énergie et surtout c'est
aussi un projet éducatif je tiens à le
dire autour d'une équipe d'élèves qui
s'organise qui organise ce Ginette avec
moi c'est en tout 130 élèves qui seront
dans l'organisation et une dizaine en
haut tout est prêt d'un point de vue
organisationnel tout est calé pour
l'instant il y a toujours quelques
difficultés de relations publiques de
dernière minute mais sinon tout est calé
quel sera le programme alors jeudi soir
le programme parce qu'il y a ce match
mais il y a toute une soirée il y a
plein d'animations diverses et variées
donc on a dû trouver d'autres gens non
il y aura un super chaud à la mi-temps
de niveau national vraiment très
original et très basket
il y aura du chant il y aura du hip-hop
il y aura beaucoup beaucoup de surprises
nouvelles et des acteurs des deux écoles
qui vont se produire et du monde
extérieur pour mélanger les excellents
il faut peut-être préciser aussi que cet
événement est seulement pour les
étudiants avec quelques invités ou si on
peut pas venir voir le match si on a
envie pour avoir le repas 78 en tout cas
voilà télé 78 il sera et c'est une
soirée privée mais avec pas mal
d'invités du monde du sport du monde la
commune média et voilà fédération est-ce
que je peux vous demander pour terminer
un petit pronostic est-ce que vous
voulez vous mouiller je pense que après
la 14e la 15e donc ce serait une bonne
chose Antoine forcément
forcément il fallait croire il faut y
croire et on y croit très fort et donc
moi je pense qu'on peut la gagner celle
là merci peut-être une saveur
particulière justement cette année
encore plus forcément moi qui perdue les
manières je veux pas être la génération
qui a fallu deux fois donc tout donner
et on va on va gagner
mais ça n'arrivera pas donc on va la
gagner enfin en tout cas on va te donner
et on verra bien jeudi soir et bien
rendez-vous jeudi soir au gymnase
Montbauron pour ce derby Ginette Hoche
qui est programmé donc ce jeudi à 20h et
donc on sera bien sûr nous TV ce
sandwich on vous rendra compte de cet
événement qui est réservé François le
disait bien sûr aux étudiants des deux
lycées et ils vont mettre l'ambiance là
je pense que c'est garanti on l'a bien
compris dans cette émission alors on va
terminer avec une dernière information
Mickaël elle concerne un certain Neymar
je pense que ça parle à peu près tout le
monde autour de la table on sait Neymar
aime le football mais
ose aime aussi la fête on le sait tous
aussi alors selon nos confrères du
Parisien plusieurs habitants de Bougival
commune ou j'en ai marre depuis 2017
sont fatigués des fêtes organisées par
leur célèbre voisin ils se sont plein
notamment d'une journée d'anniversaire
de la star le 5 février dernier la
musique latino a retentit en début
d'après-midi la fête s'est terminée aux
alentours de minuit Neymar aurait eu une
amende de 135 euros et il marque qui
jouera ce mardi 14 février avec le PSG
en quart de finale de la Ligue des
Champions face au Bayern Munich vous y
croyez à la qualification du PSG face au
Bayern Munich je sais pas si vous êtes
des fans de football mais vu de
l'extérieur comme ça avec Kylian Mbappe
qui a fait son retour dans le groupe ça
c'est une information qui est tombée
aujourd'hui enfin moi je sais pas
Antoine moi je suis aussi fan de foot
moi je suis beaucoup moins parce que
j'ai moins le temps enfin moi ces
temps-ci bon faut y croire chaque année
on y croit un jour un jour on gagnera
j'espère ils vont faire les Parisiens
parce que c'est un gros morceau la délai
8ème
le fait qu'ils vont encore perdre mais
je suis pas beaucoup le foot d'accord et
François moi je miserais plutôt sur une
victoire de Ginette
c'est peut-être un peu plus prudent avec
tout le respect que j'ai bien sûr pour
pour le lycée Hoche merci Mickaël en
tout cas pour toutes ces précisions et
avant de se quitter on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
et ce mardi matin ça reste froid dans le
département des Yvelines avec le soleil
qui est tout de même de la partie il
fera 0° à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan 1
degré avec Versailles et Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi le thermomètre va
grimper compter 12 degrés dans la partie
sud et ouest des Yvelines 11 degrés avec
Versailles 10 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
ce mardi 14 février c'est bien entendu
la Saint-Valentin vous avez prévu quoi
Michael pour la Saint-Valentin rien pour
l'instant c'est surprenant mais cette
année pour l'instant rien j'ai dit pour
l'instant en tout cas si le perso de
regarde l'émission elle n'aura pas de
d'indication pas d'indication pour pour
aujourd'hui prévu que le poème n'est pas
encore fixé avant le derby non non on va
s'entraîner avec nos ballons de basket
à nous et moi je pourrai pas la voir
mais oui je me sens l'entendre
l'esprit avant bien sûr le le duel tant
attendu de jeudi entre les Ginette et en
tout cas si vous avez envie de faire des
choses dans les Yvelines et quelques
idées épinoises vous pouvez revoir notre
émission de jeudi le 7 8 qui était
consacré notamment à quelques idées de
sortie 100% hiblinoise pour cette
Saint-Valentin bien sûr disponible sur
notre site Internet TV 78.com voilà
c'est la fin du 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité et on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]